comment s'est passée déjà raconte-nous
comment s'est passé comment que c'est
toi qui as qui a proposé à luc besson de
refaire taxi coûte on était tous les
deux mains dans la main avec malik voir
luc besson en fait ça fait longtemps
qu'on avait ce truc qui traînait un jour
ma fille m'a dit t'es sur que tu veux
pas qu'on essaye et pour tout dire on a
d'abord été parler à dominique farrugia
puisque tant par la sueur qui était chez
europe a correctement et puis il nous a
dit ben lui qui en bas on venait ont
valu par les banques là il faut porter
ses coûts justement est allé voir un
besson et lui dire ben voilà on vient de
faire un film qui s'appelle pattaya qui
a bien marché et on est des enfants de
taxi on les a tous vus c'est mon premier
souvenir de deux sorties ciné en bande
de potes et on rêverait de faire ça et
élus que nous a dit ok si vous racontez
moi et le public du luc à un monologue
je suis le pitch on va le découvrir un
petit peu là alors évidemment c'est
qu'un teaser bien s'il ya une minute
faut pas cligner des yeux sinon on va
pas y avoir grand chose à nos énormes
c'est vraiment les produits en chine à
taiwan ont dévoilé dans tpm pixar est
repris par d'abord les super fier de les
amener ici pour version alors mali tout
maliki c'est qu'hydro team juste pour
les gens de suture malik est le petit
neveu de daniel voile a été jouée par
samy naceri exactement bernard farcy
bien quoi il devient maire de marseille
et ça en très grande forme
et toi et moi je suis un flic parisien
qui est muté à marseille alors que j'ai
pas du tout envie d'y aller et je vais
être obligé de collaborer avec avec
malik est donc le seul à pouvoir
récupérer le mythique taxi et doit
arrêter le gang des italiens et on est
aussi très fier d'un truc c voilà c'est
cet italien qui doit star de la série de
morat c'est vrai c'est qu'en plus avoir
le kiff de pouvoir rouler dans ce taxi
qui nous fait rêver depuis qu on est
gosse on a en plus pu se payer des stars
qu'on adore quoi c'est un fantasme pour
nous d'avoir ce mec qui va guérir
je tiens à remercier ordures federer qui
a billet valide
[Applaudissements]